[Music]
in adopt me news submitted by Liddy
titty a lonely old Chinese man puts
himself up for adoption
oh is that lonely you really want to
suck some titty that's why I ha dirty
old man TD old man Chinese this is sad
Chinese are Mexican Chinese Chinese in
China in Chinese oh he's so lonely he
just wants some family to come like take
care of him and love him in his dying
days yeah I'll be like I want [ __ ]
relatives so they could take care of me
maybe he doesn't have any that's his
fault he should have planted his seed
where the [ __ ] are his kids Canada why
is he in Canada there know what many
kids are those they're working hard at
like a Chinese restaurant and then you
know like they're like poor and [ __ ] and
it's like we're blaming them it's
probably a Chinese racist ass restaurant
dude no no right Hong Shi yeah Hong
ching ching ching pi let me hear this
story alright so he posted a flyer that
said lonely old man in his 80s strong
body can shop cook and take care of
himself
no chronic illness I retired from a
scientific research institute an Asian
with a monthly pension of nine hundred
and forty six US dollars a month that's
pretty good for China I won't go to a
nursing home my hope is that a
kind-hearted person or family will adopt
me nourish me through old age and bury
my body when I'm dead sorry for my dad
he [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of his kids
and they're not taking care of you
there's a reason and they were like
you're not dead [ __ ] you don't go into
Canada [ __ ] [ __ ] get maple what he's
probably a dick too that's why like I
think a lot of people's no brainer if
their parents get hella old move in take
care of them
for me I'm on the fine line with my
parents even doing that or letting them
move in I'm like if you find if you're
[ __ ] blind you have cancer I might I
might have a room for you
dude my parents are hard to deal with
dude yeah you guys I think like if I
didn't know who his parents are yeah
Bart but I'm like nah I've met them yeah
we know it's funny for me okay let's
just put it like this you gotta show
them the picture of your birthday cake
as a kid with your mom's name on it
[Music]
it's good in her own tradition not even
Chinese raised her mind her mind Chinese
tradition is because you were born on
this day you have to tell me thank you
yeah Oh interesting why I kind of do
that I'd do that just down to something
I do but you don't spend all day on your
knees balancing thank you so my I mean I
buy my mom flowers on my birthday but
like it's cuz I've just been I've been
guilted so much that's true why your mom
she tells you yeah I used to do these
for your other like literally at like
you know whenever there's like I've
heard the story of my mom and how long
she was in labor for like how long 30
hours or some [ __ ] like that
pretty yeah she says you know 36 hours
hours of labor I had to give my touch
stomach sliced open for you and wanted
to yeah fine we're putting up scars like
this long
old school see wait you don't have
siblings right no it's just me too
that's why that's why it's all when you
have slipped siblings you spread the
[ __ ] love like you like yeah you you
take it this year man you take it yeah
so I was gonna feel like I'm all they
got let me let me be nice well that's
what's supposed to happen yeah when you
have siblings that's what's supposed to
happen but Bart's got a [ __ ] up
because because he's not only the only
child but both of his parents are still
single and so he gets the extra
attention
and separate yeah yeah see I have a
brother and then we kind of like
whatever my mom talks to him talk to me
whatever but once she got married again
she was out of my life and I was like oh
thank you am I in my hearts of hearts
like I wanted to see your parents like
see each other and then sparks happen
mm-hmm but it was not that at all no
like when you actually see it yeah
disgusted at each other ever seen
somebody hate somebody that much with
their eyes like his mom did this I saw
his dad like his dad comes in Buddhist a
fairy this is mom he goes she goes
disgusted of a human being did she hates
his guts so they had like made sweet
love that night y'all be tight with it
how can you carry that hate for so long
I don't know but that's a mad like dude
you're not my homie my god yes oh this
man and now we're talking about here the
lonely man he titled the flyer looking
for someone to adopt me that's adorable
my name is Han Han Solo I'm so long
thank you it's funny today guys he's all
by himself
yeah so his book went viral and his
phone started going off the hook and he
made some friends but he didn't get a
loving family to adopt him and later on
he passed oh yeah [ __ ] story yeah we
might and it was gonna be something else
like hey adopt me and then someone fat
but now he just [ __ ] die for some
reason our viewers really likes that
story they submit so many our viewers
are sadistic they know that we're gonna
clown ha ha ha and they want to hear all
the funny [ __ ] we have is a wonder
how terrible of a person that he was
that his kids didn't bring him over
yeah so one of his sons that lives in
Canada he denied that flier he was like
no my father you know he's not lonely he
his kids take good care of him but he
wouldn't provide any details to like
further paluzzo my dad's also a con
artist no like it seems like the son
couldn't prove more details to prove
that his story is true which is that he
takes care of his dad and is not lonely
in stuff so I don't know people probably
give him a lot of [ __ ] give him the son
[ __ ] like hey MA yeah yeah yeah yeah but
in his final days one of his friends
took him to the hospital so he didn't
die alone that's nice I remember I was
like reading some [ __ ] like where people
are like you should never disrespect
your parents and you should NAB you
gotta cherish that I'm like [ __ ] you
are lucky that you feel that way and
think everyone should do that do you
know how many [ __ ] up deadbeats there
are in this world mmm you have drug
addict parents that leave you like
[ __ ] in the dust and then you have to
take care of them you have to you know
yeah and then it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
they're so blinded it's like your
experience with your parents that's
that's just you right there's a lot of
people out there that don't have the
same type of [ __ ] yeah cuz if your
parents popped you out and then looked
at you like you were a burden like it
out it mean like what do you owe them
you weren't asked to be brought to this
world yeah true
you know yeah I definitely feel like you
know I try to give old people the
benefit of the doubt you know I'm saying
like yeah you know most of my elders but
then like of course there are [ __ ]
old people that don't necessarily
deserve to be respected you know that I
love angry old people do they crack me
up that's why old people don't
understand why old people always get it
passed does he live in a rapist you
don't know sure it's just like the baby
effect you know they like all the other
sweet they're ancient
they're like double our lifetime and
some I always think like damn you start
to understand why old people are so like
mean cuz like as we get older like I'm
definitely like it's not that I'm grumpy
er you tolerate less [ __ ] yeah yeah
exactly usually you're over the [ __ ]
you don't sound like man I don't want to
deal with this you know so like I
imagine like double my life am I gonna
be even like man [ __ ] these kids cuz I'm
already like I'm already all my [ __ ]
these kids yeah you know say I was like
a man when I'm really or don't be like
oh I just hate everybody just a kid
going down it's not on a skateboard
yeah you push them well what you're so
old that everyone looks like infants to
you because you're like 80 and then a 20
year old is like oh I don't [ __ ] know
man old people I just don't give them a
pass if you're an [ __ ] you were
probably a so when you were a lot
younger too they're probably even bigger
[ __ ] yeah cuz they're a lot more
power into your words I don't know all
right I guess I just don't have much to
contribute when it comes to old people
because I wasn't really ever around old
people same you know and what's your
what's your definition of people to like
could run without one guy that was
yellow yes okay oh he's not all if they
look like my mom they're not old okay
they're like my mom's age to me they're
like oh they're just older but they're
not if there's it is completely wrinkled
and that's in there that's when they're
old yeah they're have full head of white
hair yeah then that's old but like I
don't know I think because I just didn't
really have grandparents around and just
will be but I don't know how to be
remind you close with your grandma no
not at all oh really
no no I love my grandparents is my
grandparents are still alive cool they
can move in with us
any day and I keep my parents out I love
my grandparents too but that woman beat
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me you know what
the real problem here is he should have
fit the stereotype and learn martial
arts because kung fu old guys are still
cool and they always have customers yeah
YouTube channel something you know like
I don't know when you get old and you
don't know kung fu and you're Asian
you're kind of useless that's true what
if he knows Tai Chi Tai Chi's boring you
don't get booze it's gotta be something
that attracts young you gotta get bricks
and break it on your dick yeah
then you're still useful as the old man
you hear that Dad
get on it there's your dad watch
everything he doesn't watch the JK
News's but he watches my videos well
then you just said that for no reason no
no I'm gonna play this one for him
specifically okay and then I'm gonna
just grab a brick and throw it at his
dick
[Music]